Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan. Wir sitzen vor dem Salon. Ich muss dich aber zunächst fragen, hält die Koalition?
Ja, also über Mande und Einflugsschneise suchen, würde ich sagen, in 17 Medien noch 317 mal nachgefragt, dann nicht und falls nicht, dann doch.
Ja, das ist, glaube ich, die adäquate Antwort, die man nach dieser Medienberichterstattung geben kann. Regierungskrise hieß es schon in der Bildzeitung, da wurden nochmal schnell Podcasts am Abend nachgeliefert.
Ja, sowieso.
Weil man dringend nochmal drüber sprechen muss, ob es jetzt den ganz großen Krach gibt. Wir werden dieses Thema im Salon vertiefen. Ja, ich überrasche dich mit etwas. Ich verrate es auch schon. Ich habe dir vor wenigen Tagen geschrieben, immer hast du irgendein Programm, das du mir nennen kannst, mit dem man eine Audiodatei transkribieren kann. Dann hast du mir so gleich einen Link geschickt. Das habe ich dann auch verwendet, dieses Programm. Was habe ich transkribiert? Ich habe transkribiert, die Sendung Miowska spricht mit Friedrich Merz. Wir hatten hier vor einiger Zeit mal Clips gespielt aus Talkshows und haben nur die Fragen gespielt, die hatte ich mal mitgefragt. Und jetzt habe ich das Spiel ein bisschen weitergetrieben. Ich dachte mir, jetzt daraus Clips zu machen, ist eigentlich unsinnig. Man muss tatsächlich die Fragen von Karen Miowska einmal sich transkribieren lassen und wir werden sie lesen. Und wir werden uns fragen, was stimmt eigentlich mit diesem Journalismus nicht, der die Gelegenheit hat, 60 Minuten lang mit dem Bundeskanzler zu reden und dann diese Fragen zu stellen. Es geht mir nicht darum, dass ich jetzt sagen will, Miowska hat nicht hart genug nachgefragt, sondern meine Argumente sind andere. Es ist hochaufschussreich. Wenn man den Text so im Ganzen liest, könnte man auch sagen, ist vielleicht was für den Ingeborg-Bachmann-Preis, könnte man einreichen. Es ist hochaufschussreich und erschreckend. Das gibt es jedenfalls von mir im Salon. Und da gibt es natürlich auch die Frage, hält dann die Koalition?
Ja, also es hatte ja kleine Nachspiele, dass wir das schon mal gemacht haben, dass du das schon mal gemacht hast. Und ich kann jetzt nebulös sagen, bevor ich höre, was sie fragt, dass meine Reaktion, da ich ungefähr in dem Alter bin wie ihre Redaktion, ungefähr genau die Reaktion ist wie die der Redaktion, während die selber Backstage sitzen und sich die Sendung anhören. Denn da arbeiten ja Leute, die bereiten was vor und so. Und dann lässt sich Karen Mioska wissend aus den Tagesthemen, dass ihr Durchschnittsalter 71 ist, die Leute schon seit zehn Jahren nicht mehr im Beruf und so weiter und so fort. Also was eben bedeutet, das gehört zum Urlaub bis ans Lebensende, dass man nicht mehr so richtig teilnimmt an der Gesellschaft, wie sie ist, weil man es nicht muss. Und es ist natürlich blöd, wenn man unter diesen Bedingungen Fernsehen macht.
Und es ist ein fundamentales Missverständnis, abzulesen hier im Verhältnis Politik-Journalismus. Denn kritisch nachfragen, ein bisschen bohren, bedeutet nicht gleich kritisch nachfragen, in dem Sinne. Wenn man nicht bereit ist, über Inhalte zu sprechen, dann ist man eigentlich nicht mehr weit entfernt von Ben ungeskriptet, setzt sich einfach hin und hat einen Politiker da und der ist den vier Stunden lang quatschen.
Aber er möchte wissen, was das für eine Person ist.
Für ein Mensch.
Für ein Mensch. Ja. So, wir gratulieren natürlich Friedrich Merz erst mal zu einem überstandenen Jahr. Derzeit, es wird ja nicht so richtig abgerechnet. Ich will kurz rekapitulieren. Friedrich Merz trat ja mal als CDU-Chef an und hat gewonnen nicht. Dann trat er noch mal an und gewann nicht. Trat er noch mal an und gewann. Und dann wollte er Bundeskanzler werden. Er trat an und gewann nicht. Und dann trat er noch mal an und dann gewann er. Und es gab, ob in Alexander Erklärung darüber, wie die linken jetzt und überhaupt und so. Und in dieser Folge, ja, die setzt sich halt fort mit. Und dann trat er an zu regieren. Und es gab halt bisher alle lange keine Abrechnung. Aber wir wissen, egal, welche KPIs man jetzt nehmen würde, es gelang halt nicht. Ja. So. Es gibt aber auch keinen zweiten Versuch. Das ist halt das Blöde. Also Chef kann man erst mal werden. Und Kanzler auch. Aber danach ist man ja halt in der Verantwortung so. Und wenn man eine Geschichte des Verlierens und Losens und auch eine Geschichte der von außen herangetragenen Nacherzählung es an sich selbst gescheitert mit sich führt, dann sieht ein 70-jähriges Lebensalter halt genauso aus. Deswegen schicken wir Leute typischerweise, und es ist nicht dispektierlich oder so, aber denkt mal wirklich über den Gedanken nach. Warum schicken wir die über 65-Jährigen in Rente? Das ist schon eine Aussage hinsichtlich, die Jüngeren können es besser. Du bist nicht mehr so leistungsfähig. Kümmer dich jetzt um dich. Wir geben dir die Freiheit dafür und Geld. Und Deutschland so, nee, wir geben einem 70-Jährigen die wichtigste Rolle des Landes. Und es ist absolut normal, da zu scheitern. Es ist halt nur einfach schade, weil es gäbe ja noch andere Kandidaten, die auch Kanzler sein könnten, und die kommen halt jetzt gerade nicht zum Zug. Also sozusagen doppelt blöd. Nicht nur haben wir einen blöden Kanzler, wir haben auch keinen guten. Also muss man doppelt verrechnen. Und in deren Sicht sieht die Bilanz düster aus. Die Frage ist, könnte man im Journalismus nicht genau so darüber reden? Also man kann ja durchaus bedauern, dass ein, jetzt hat er die Altersgrenze 66, aber er ist doch so eine Koryphäe in was weiß ich, Forschung und so. Aber die Professur ist halt trotzdem vorbei. Und deshalb kann es dann nicht so. Und dafür müsste man eigentlich ehrlich, ernsthaft, wahrhaftig. Und ich würde sagen, man kann auch schön darüber reden. Es ist ja nicht so, dass man jetzt die 70-Jährigen, man kann ja von denen auch viel erfahren und viel lernen und so weiter. Also es ist ja, wenn man ihnen halt den Ort gibt und die Rollenbeschreibung und da auch wohlwollend mit umgeht, kann das ja alles gelingen, aber es gelingt halt gerade nicht.
Nur ist es so, dass du sagen würdest, dass ein 40-jähriger Friedrich Merz besser gewesen wäre? Ich habe da meine Zweifel. Also das Alter bringt natürlich einige Dinge mit, die es schwieriger machen zu regieren und sich anzupassen, auch an neue Gegebenheiten. Und jetzt ist Friedrich Merz ohnehin nicht für besondere geistige Flexibilität bekannt, was dann alles noch hinzukommt. Aber ein 40-jähriger Friedrich Merz, ich meine, ich habe sein Buch gelesen, was er so veröffentlicht hat mit etwa 50 zum Thema Sozialstaat und Deutschland und wie er das so alles sieht, da wird einem genauso Angst und Bange wie bei dem 70-jährigen Friedrich Merz.
Das stimmt. Und diese Pointe ist gut. Ich möchte sie mit einer Pointe kontern. Wenn wir jetzt vergleichen, der 50-jährige Joe Biden gegen den 70-jährigen, dann sehen wir andere Reden, andere Leistungsfähigkeit, andere Termindichte. Da wäre einfach mehr los. So. Und dasselbe gilt für Donald Trump. Und jetzt gilt für Friedrich Merz dasselbe wie bei Donald Trump gilt. Trotz allem, was ich eben gesagt habe, schließe ich jetzt an mit, zum Glück ist er 70 und nicht 50.
Ja, ich weiß, was du sagen willst.
Jeder denkt sich jetzt selber den Teil. Miriam Lau war gestern im Deutschlandfunk und ließ sich interviewen zum Thema Merz, ein Jahr Merz. Und ich hab gedacht, es kann, also es geht einfach alles nicht. Es ist so, wir wissen alle, wie Merz behandelt wird. Das große rhetorische Talent, leider mal wieder gescheitert, aber da er gerade an seiner eigenen Rede gescheitert ist und beim ersten und beim zweiten Mal und beim ersten Kanzlerwahlgang und nichts geklappt hat, betonen wir einfach immer wieder, eigentlich ist er ein rhetorisches Talent. Also durch das Scheitern kommt überhaupt erst der Nimbus zustande, weil der Journalismus, der das beobachtet, bescheuert ist. Also es ist einfach eine Fehlspezifikation im System.
Also für die Leute, die Mariam Lau nicht kennen, Mariam Lau ist bei der Zeit und sie hat auch ein Buch über Friedrich Merz geschrieben.
Und lässt sich gerne einladen, um der Alten Republik nochmal zu erklären, von wem sie regiert wird.
Bin gespannt.
Und sie macht hier folgenden Spruch zum Thema, ja, aber hat ja Merz sich nicht sehr oft im Ton vergriffen.
Das wäre besser, wenn er seine Stimmung besser nachrecherchieren würde. Also wie ist das mit der Zahnbehandlung? Zuwanderer, Asylbewerber, können die sich wirklich die Zähne machen lassen auf Kosten der Krankenkassen, Beitragszahler. So, und dann hätte man schon mal einen Ärger weniger. Aber wie gesagt, trotzdem glaube ich...
Blablabla. Wie ist das jetzt? Hätte er mal seine Stimmung durchrecherchieren sollen? Und ich meine, der Bundestag hat schon einen wissenschaftlichen Dienst. So eine Art Clot-Recherche-Werkzeug in menschlicher Form. Wie sich der Papst es wünscht, wie wir heute lernen werden. Das Bundeskanzleramt ist selbst ein wissenschaftlicher Dienst. Mehrere Referate, die themenspezifisch dem Bundeskanzler zuarbeiten. Jetzt sagt sie, hätte er da nicht mal, und ich würde sagen, kurz drüber nachdenken können. Antwort, ja. Hätte man vor einer öffentlichen Kommunikation als Bundeskanzler grundsätzlich seine Referate fragen müssen. Antwort ist natürlich, ja natürlich, was sonst. All das passiert nicht. Und jetzt kommt sie mit. Na ja, hätte er da mal ein bisschen nachrecherchiert bei seiner Stimmung. Wie ist das jetzt, wenn ein Migrant das Wartezimmer eines Arzt, einer Arztpraxis betritt, müssen dann alle anderen sofort raus, weil jetzt plötzlich ein VIP reingekommen ist. Die Antwort ist natürlich nein. Und sie sagt, hätte er darüber mal kurz nachgedacht, hätte ein Ärger weniger. So, das mit dem ein Ärger ist so ein bisschen problematisch, wenn es ganz viele ein Ärger gibt. Ja, also die Paschas, völlig vermurkste Wahlkampfreden. Ich stelle mich als Kandidat vor, ich habe gar keinen Skript. Ach so, ach damit überzeug ich hier niemanden. Ach so, ja gut, dann versuche ich halt dreimal hier gewählt zu werden. Also reden, die komplett misslegen. Jede einzelne Botschaft vor der Öffentlichkeit völlig misslungen. Sitz bei Lanz, sagt irgendwas die kleinen Paschas, redet was vom Stadtbild, drei Tage später bringt er seine Töchter rein. Jedes Mal wird es schlimmer. Also wir haben ja auf gar keinen Fall mal so einen Ärger. Hätte mal über... Mittlerweile ist ja so, wenn hier sie redet über Zahnärzte, bei Friedrich Merz und Zahnärzten weiß man gar nicht, um was geht es jetzt eigentlich? Geht es noch um seine Aussage, dass die Migranten da irgendwie die Zahnarztermine weggehen? Oder geht es schon um seinen CDU-Wirtschaftsrat, der sagt, wir brauchen gar keine Zahnärzte mehr? Also man kommt ja völlig durcheinander mittlerweile.
Das liegt ja mal daran und deshalb auch immer wieder der Rückgriff auf das große rhetorische Talent, das man von 1997 mal offenbar so irgendwo gehört hat, ist, dass sie ein Ideal des Kanzlers haben, dem er bitte zu entsprechen habe. Und wenn dieses Bild einmal von ihm unterlaufen wird und dann auch hundertmal unterlaufen wird, dann sagen sie, ja das hätte er da und dort so wohl nicht machen können. Bitte errichte uns wieder das Idealbild, das wir uns mal 1997 von dir gemacht haben.
Ja, es ist einfach völlig...
Es ist der Kanzler jetzt, der da ist. Es ist nicht der Kanzler, der Idealkanzler, der regiert und dann gibt es leider schon mal den, der kurz ausschert. Sondern es gibt nur den Kanzler.
Genau, da fühlst du dich schon auf den richtigen Weg, denn ich finde es ja selber quatschig die ganze Zeit, G-Jack hier und blau und so, aber wir kommen jetzt um das Phantom, wir haben den Rediker angesprochen, das Phantasma, G-Jack, um, wie ich sage, virtuelle Sachen nicht herum. Diese Journalisten leben in ihrer eigenen Traumwelt, in der sie so Bibi Blocksberg gehört haben und ihr Bild vom Bundeskanzler, vom dortigen Bürgermeister ableiten, wie er vorgestellt wird. So, ja. Direkt nach diesem Spruch, ja, würde er sich über die Zahnärzte ein bisschen mehr informieren, hätte ein Ärger weniger, sagt Mariam Lau folgendes.
Es ist immer irgendwie was Wahres dran. Und darauf kann man sich auch ruhig mal einlassen.
So, es ist ja angeblich, sagt sie, immer was Wahres dran. Bei Friedrichs Merz Botschaften ist nirgendwo etwas Wahres dran. Man kann gar nicht beschreiben, wie weit in Phantasmer wir hier sind. Diese Zeit, die Merz jetzt Deutschland, sagen wir mal seit 2018, er kommt zurück, er möchte da antreten, Merkel ist weg und wie auch immer, sie sagt, sie will nicht mehr. So, nur in den Themen, bei denen ich mich auskenne, ja. 2015 darf sich nicht wiederholen, weil es ist jetzt seit zehn Jahren der Satz. 2015 ist das einzige Jahr, in dem sich die deutsche Bevölkerung mal verjüngt hat. Wer genau bei diesem Jahr sagt, das darf sich nicht wiederholen, hat einfach einen kompletten Knall. Und da ist auch nicht was wahres dran oder so.
Und wir lesen heute ein ganzes Buch, das das noch mal sehr deutlich unterstreicht.
In dem, in dem.
Von Frank-Potollo. Na, der sagt man ja schon mit Migration, wie viel Netto, Zuwanderung benötigt würde um.
Ja, genau. Genau, wir kriegen nachher eine gute Migrationsanlage.
Wir kriegen auch ein anderes Buch, das das nicht so beschreibt, ja.
Genau, ja.
Stimmt.
Das zweite ist, ich bleib mal bei meinem Thema. Wir haben Migranten in Deutschland. Wir liegen achtfach über dem Durchschnitt des Migrationsanteils der Länder der Welt. Achtfach. Das ist ein Wert, den erreicht nicht mal die Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika. Wir sind das heterogene Land, nicht Amerika. Man hört immer hier Chinatown da, irgendwas da und dann machen die alle so, nee, Deutschland ist das. Banusviertel, Offenbach, selbst ostdeutsche Dörfer, ja, haben einfach Migration. So. Und wie man da einen Migrationsdiskurs führt, in dem man einfach sagt, also einer, der sich richtig gut macht in der Regierung ist der Innenminister, der hält sich sowohl mit Söder als auch mit Merz total ausbalanciert und alle finden ihn gut. Der Typ schickt für 20.000 Euro am Tag oder so Hubschrauber in den Wald, damit da irgendwelche in Soldatenkluft mit Waffen behangene Polizisten Migranten abwehren, die da gar nicht sind. Das ist die Politik. Und wenn hier irgendwer irgendwas dazu sagt, ist da gar nichts Wahres dran. Da ist nichts Wahres dran. In diesen Sprüchen, die wir aus der CDU hören, ist nichts Wahres dran.
Es ist auch nichts Wahres dran, wenn Friedrich Merz glaubt, dass die wirtschaftliche Schwäche Deutschlands gerade darin begründet liegt, dass viele Leute gerne eine Work-Life-Balance hätten und von einer Vier-Tage-Woche träumen. Denn diese ist nicht Realität. Sie ist sehr weit weg. Und diese Debatte darüber verändert noch nicht das BIP. Das ist völliger Unsinn. Wenn man hier jetzt sagt, ja, ein dumpfes Gefühl haben wir immer alle zu allem irgendetwas. Und das ruft Friedrich Merz ab. Und das identifiziert man dann als das Wahre, das da dran ist. Ja, dann ist man aber so schiefgewekelt. Dann macht man wirklich nur noch das Leben ein Traum. Dann macht man eine virtuelle Berichterstattung über eine virtuelle Politik.
Die Realität ist, ja, es gibt Messerstecher, die dann auf Kindergartengruppen einstechen. Und wir haben durchaus kleine Kinder, die sich weiden wie Paschas. So, dass das nicht zwingend mit Migration zu tun hat, wissen wir auch. Also wenn Gewalt irgendwo zu suchen ist, dann ja wohl in der bio-deutschen Ehe kurz vor Renteneintritt. Oder weil man einen Pflegefall oben im Dach geschlossen hat, und so langsam die Geduld verliert. Nur aktuelle Zahlen, ja. In Sachen Migration, die migrantische Bevölkerung, erste Generation, also Leute, die wirklich im Ausland geboren sind und in Deutschland jetzt leben und arbeiten. Und, wie wir wissen, 7.000 Euro pro Nase in die Sozialkasse einzahlen. Deshalb wir viel mehr Einwanderung in die Sozialkasse bräuchten, weil sonst keine Sozialkasse mehr. Die sind im Schnitt fast zehn Jahre jünger als die bio-deutsche Bevölkerung. Die bringen also genau den Puffer mit, den wir brauchen, um die jetzt in die Rentekommende Boomer zu finanzieren. Nimmt man deren Kinder noch hinzu? Also Kinder, die schon wieder in Deutschland geboren wurden, aber von ausländischen Eltern. Dann liegen die sogar elf Jahre unter dem deutschen Schnitt. Elf Jahre klingt gar nicht so viel, ist aber bei einer 47-jährigen Bevölkerung im Schnitt 20 Prozent. Das sind genau diese Puffer, die wir brauchen. Was haben wir für einen Diskurs? Also da ist nichts wahres dran. Kannst du eigentlich deutlich genug sagen. Es ist überhaupt gar nichts wahres dran, wenn aus der CDU jemand öffentlich kommunizieren. Vor allem nicht in spontaner Gefühlsregung. So, Mariam Lau, zur Koalitionslage. Wir haben ja Friedrich Merz, Lars Klingbeier. Jetzt hören wir die ganze Zeit, die verstehen sich ja nicht so gut, wo ich mir denke. Also die Arbeiten im Metier der Politik, da gilt einfach 50 Prozent plus X Mehrheit besiegelt. Dass man das historisch hintereinander verketten und deswegen der Kompromiss, so eine Zauberkraft erringt. Okay, gut. Man muss sich halt abstimmen. Kennt man ja. Aber wir sind trotzdem in der Politik. Da regieren zwei verschiedene Parteien, bei denen wir uns drüber lustig machen. Wenn die eine im Podcast sagt, ja, dann kann man doch, wenn man bei dem Thema mal die Grünen wählen oder so. Absurd. So, es regieren SPD und CDU. Das sind zwei unterschiedliche Parteien. Miriam Lau zum neuen Verständnis dieser beiden.
Also eine Zeit lang war das so, jedenfalls meine Beobachtung, dass dieses Scharnier Kanzler, Vizekanzler, Merz Klingball, das hat sehr, sehr gut funktioniert, auch deshalb, weil man sich ideologisch eigentlich nicht so wahnsinnig fern ist.
Ja, das ist aber ein Problem, wenn das die Diagnose ist. Ja, das ist das Problem.
Also beide wollen Wachstum, schlicht und ergreifend.
Welcher Politiker will kein Wachstum?
Wirklich, das ist so grotesk. Beide wollen Wachstum. Ja, ich würde mir wünschen, dass der eine sagt, ich will Wachstum, wir müssen sofort Panzer kaufen, jeder Panzer bringt so viel BIP und so weiter, und dann wird das nächstes Jahr verrechnet. Und dann will ich eine andere Partei, die sagt, ich will auch Wachstum, wir investieren in Kinder, jedes kriegt sie sieben Euro pro investiertem Euro zurück, aber erst in elf Jahren. So, das ist beides Wachstum. Aber das kann man doch nicht unter einem Nenner, ja eigentlich sind die sich voll nah und überhaupt, na gibt es gar keinen Grund für Konflikte. Was ist denn das für ein politischer Journalismus, den man dazu macht?
Vorausgesetzt wird hier, dass jede sozialdemokratische oder gar grüne oder linke Maßnahme, die ergriffen wird, per se wachstumsfeindlich ist, weil damit der Sozialstaat aufgebaut wird und wenn der Sozialstaat größer wird, dann schwächt das das Wachstum. Das ist ja die Prämisse, die dem zu Grunde liegt, die falsch ist. Deshalb ist alles, was uns, also den Arbeitnehmern etwas zumutet, was auch nötige, aber auch harte Reformen bedeutet, das bedeutet immer Wachstum. Und wenn jetzt also Klingbeil harte Reformen ankündigt und Merz sagt, genau das wollen wir auch, dann sieht das für Mariam Lau so aus, als seien die auf einem Wachstumsfahrt, während alle anderen, die sagen, wir müssten zum Beispiel mehr investieren in Bildung, als die Idioten dastehen, die ja keine Ahnung von Wachstum haben. Das ist aber einfach eine Verblendung bei besagter Journalistin.
Ich will auch eine kleine Transferleistung anbieten, einfach nur beim drüber nachdenken, also reine Heuristik jetzt. Wir erleben gerade das De-Coupling, Wirtschaftswachstum, ohne dass der CO2-Ausstoß im gleichen Maße steigt. Also Elektrifizierung, was auch immer.
Um das gar nicht zu sagen, kein absolutes De-Coupling, weil wir sonst gleich eine E-Mail bekommen, aber wir erleben das, ich will das auch deutlich unterstreichen, mehr als wir gedacht haben, dass das möglich ist.
Genau. So, das sehen wir aber vor allem, weil in Amerika eine Doktrin vorherrscht, ich muss Krieg im Iran führen wegen dem Öl. Oder ein wildes Zuehler oder was auch immer. Mit der, kann man jetzt flapsig sagen, unintendierten Nebenfolge, dass wenn Trump sagt, also wenn ich keinen Öl von den Iraner kriege, gar keiner, dass die ganze Welt sagt, ach so ohne Öl jetzt, ja gut, dann fahren wir jetzt erstmal nach China und kaufen einen. So, also dieses Decoupling wird nun zufälligerweise genau von denen herangetrieben, wo ich mir denke, ja, also wenn der Habeck Weg nicht geht, es versöhnlich zu machen, machen wir es halt einfach über kurz vor Weltkrieg. So, aber der Effekt ist derselbe. Was aber bedeutet, es gibt ja eine Alternative. Also wir könnten auch, wer mir diese Kompetenzunterstellung bei der CDU letztens ausformuliert, die CDU betritt die politische Bühne und sagt, wir müssen jetzt alle leiden, denn wer schön sein will, muss leiden. Wer reich sein will, muss leiden. Und ich denke mir, nö, das kann man ja auch dekappeln. Also man kann genauso ohne so eine fetischistische, sadistische, wir müssen jetzt alle leiden. Also es muss ja kein Krebstumor aus dem Gehirn ausgerupert werden. Wir wollen ja einfach nur Wachstum so, ja. Also wir müssen jetzt alle leiden. Und ich würde sagen, nee, man muss jetzt nicht Oma Erna noch mal davon überzeugen, nur weil der Arzt gesagt hat, oh, das wird jetzt kurz pieksen, dass der Kanzler nur dann kompetent ist, wenn er sagt, oh, das wird jetzt kurz pieksen. So, aber gut, wärme jetzt diesen Weg nicht. Ich möchte nur holistisch anmerken, ja, also das wäre durchaus möglich. Wir können doch einfach den H-Bag Weg gehen. Wir hätten jetzt wahrscheinlich sogar weniger Wärmepumpen gerade im Verkauf, weil das, was Trump da veranstaltet, also Wärmepumpe ist gerade das Ding in Deutschland. Einfach mal kein politischer Diskurs, sondern einfach nur jeder Einzelne, der sich kurz durchkalkulieren will, was bringt mir eine Wärmepumpe? Und dann sagen die, ja, kostet 20.000 mehr, aber rentiert sich ab Jahr drei. Zack, kaufen die Leute eine Wärmepumpe. Oh, Wunder, ja. Also, ist schon verrückt. So, jetzt M. Lau zum Vierten. Eigentlich könnte man sagen, hier gibt es nichts mehr zu kommentieren. Alles versteht sich von selbst. Also, damit möchte ich sagen, ich weiß, liebe Hörer, ihr seid unser Publikum, ihr seid wahnsinnig klug. Wir müssten jetzt nichts dazu sagen. Aber Wolfgang wird diesen Clip jetzt hören. Und natürlich haben wir einfach Lust, was dazu zu sagen. Also, wir hören jetzt Mariam Lau zum Vierten.
Wie ist ihre Einschätzung? In welche Richtung sollte er als erstes nachbessern?
Wenn man sich mal erinnert an diese eine Ansprache, die Angela Merkel, die ja auch ein eher verschlossener Typ war, mal gehalten hat während der Corona-Krise. Es ist ernst, nehmen sie es auch ernst. So eine Art von Ansprache wünsche ich mir. Ich glaube, ich würde dem Land gut tun, einfach alle mal zusammen sammeln, so ein kleines politisches Lagerfeuer entzünden und sagen, wir brauchen euch alle.
Ja, eine schöne, wärmende Volksgemeinschaft brauchen wir. Was hat das eine mit dem anderen zu tun? Merkel hält eine Rede angesichts einer Pandemie. Wir wissen noch nicht, wohin die Reise geht. Ein Virus, ein Problem muss gelöst werden. Wir können noch nicht sagen, genau wie. Wir müssen uns jetzt erst einmal zurücknehmen, damit das Virus nicht sich weiter ausbreitet. Jetzt stehen wir in Deutschland vor sehr verschiedenen wirtschaftlichen, demografischen und sonstigen Herausforderungen. Wie soll dieses Lagerfeuer vor irgendetwas bringen? Weil bei Merkel war ja nicht ein Lagerfeuer, sondern sie sagte ja, wir bleiben jetzt mal zu Hause und schauen dann, wie sich das entwickelt und sie da das geht dann runter, die Inzidenzen. Und dann fängt man an zu schauen, wie kann man damit umgehen? Masken, Impfungen und so weiter. Hier kann man ja nur eine wir gehören alle zusammen Rede, was immer die größte Lüge der Welt ist, halten, bei der aber danach nichts anderes entsteht, außer zu sagen naja gut, aber jetzt hat sich trotzdem mein Portemonnaie nicht verändert. An der Tankzäule sieht es immer noch genauso aus. Nichts verändert sich dadurch. Was also Mariam Lau hier eigentlich einfordert, ist das, was die Journalisten immer sich wünschen, dass so ein großes Wir beschworen wird, einfach nur damit sie sich in Berlin gut fühlen. Aber davon können wir uns leider hier in Frankfurt, Copens und sonst wo nichts kaufen.
Also Friedrich Merz ist ja, wie wir wissen, ein rhetorisches Talent. Ich glaube, die Transferleistung wäre von ihm zu schultern, zu sagen, Momentchen mal, die Miriam Lau, die hat eigentlich recht. Merkel hat ja damals bei einem Virus gesagt, es ist ernst, also nehmen sie es ernst, was ist eigentlich mein Virus gerade? Okay, die Krise besteht darin, dass wir wieder so Inflationssprünge haben, weil uns Rohöl fehlt, alle Angst haben, wie auch immer. Die Ursache dafür, also was ist das Äquivalent des Virus? Ah ja, Trumps Dummheit. Und ehrlich gesagt, ja, Miriam Lau, ich wünsche mir eine Rede von Friedrich Merz zum Thema. Trumps Dummheit ist so gefährlich wie das Coronavirus. Bitte erinnern Sie sich? Nehmen Sie es selbst. Genau, das Problem ist nur, Friedrich Merz war ja in der Einschulklasse und hat dort quasi gesagt, also Trumps Dummheit. Da kommen natürlich gleich wieder drei Robin-Alexander-Podcasts, die uns erklären, das verstehe ich gar nicht, der Merz muss doch wissen, dass er immer als Kanzler spricht, auch vor Schülern und so. Ja, und es wird gleich wieder eingehegt.
Wir kommen jetzt auch da nochmal bei Bioska, kommt natürlich darauf auch zu sprechen.
Aber ich bin total dafür zu sagen, ja, halt mal bitte eine Rede zum Thema, das ist ernst, nehmen Sie es ernst, und dann wird das aber ausformuliert.
Ja.
Was ist hier gerade so ernst?
Ja, und dann können wir über Deindustrialisierung mal sprechen.
Ich bin gerne ans Lagerfeuer.
Wir können mal darüber sprechen, dass die EU sinnlose Zölle gegen China verhängt, sodass die wirtschaftlichen Beziehungen zu China schlechter werden. Wir können darüber reden, dass Reich ja alles torpediert, was die Klimatransformation vorantreiben könnte und damit auch Wachstum schaffen würde. Über all das könnte man mal reden. Da braucht man aber kein politisches Lagerfeuer, sondern da muss man dann tatsächlich mal das ansprechen, was der Fall ist. Und das wollen diese Journalisten ja nicht. Sie wollen wirklich nur ein Gefühl. Also eigentlich suchen sie ja ein Papst. Also eigentlich suchen sie ja jemand, der ein paar gute Worte für einen hat. Aber der Papst spricht halt klüger und politischer als das, was die Journalisten eigentlich vom Kanzler erwarten. Es ist so dramatisch eigentlich dieser gesamte deutsche Politikbereich, Berichterstattungs- und Meinungsjournalismus, dass man's, also ich krieg's ja auch nur noch in geringen Dosen mit. Dann setze ich mich so in einem Myoska-Gespräch von einer Stunde aus, hab da schon das Transkript, streiche dann die Narzanworten raus und habe das dann vor mir und denke mir, das ist eine solche Verblödung, die da stattfindet. Wir müssen wirklich über nichts mehr diskutieren mit, wie können wir irgendwie Social Media beschränken oder so. Also hier, das ist, das hier ist eine Verblödungsmaschine, das kriegt keinen Algorithmus hin.
Ja, der Papst ist so klug, ich möchte eine Pointe schon mal vor die Paywall ziehen, damit ihr hört, wie klug es immer hinter der Paywall zugeht. Der Papst, Leo XIV., wir haben aufgeklagert, er ist nicht der 16. oder der 14. hat beim Welttag für Social Media oder so vor Jugendlichen eine Rede gehalten und in der formuliert er, ich will jetzt nicht sagen, die Gefahren vor der KI, denn er möchte es versöhnlich gestalten, aber er sagt, eine Bedrohung heute im zwischenmenschlichen Beisammensein sind nichtgedachte Gedanken. Im Sinne von, da hat kein Mensch in Einheit von Geist und Leib und so im Antlitz eines anderen einen Fortschritt im Dialog gesucht, wodurch Gedanken entstehen, sondern es gibt jetzt nichtgedachte Gedanken. Profane Menschen würden jetzt sagen, die KI halluziniert oder sowas. Und ich sehe das im Journalismus aber auch. Wir haben es hier von Miriam Lau zum Beispiel mit wirklich nichtgedachten Gedanken. Das sind nicht nur einfach undurchdachte Gedanken oder so, sondern das sind nichtgedachte Gedanken. Miriam Lau unterstellt März. Er habe bei öffentlicher Kommunikation nicht so richtig nachgedacht und sich dadurch Ärger eingehandelt. Und meine Frage ist, wie viel Denken steckt denn in den geäußerten Gedanken von Miriam Lau zu diesem Sachverhalt? Und die Antwort ist Null. Also der nichtgedachte Gedanke ist jetzt eine echte Gefahr. Und es hat gar nicht mehr nur mit KI zu tun.
Und wenn man ernsthaft sagt, egal auf welcher politischen Seite man steht, aber wenn man ernsthaft als Journalist sagt, wir brauchen ein politisches Lagerfeuer und die Ansprache muss sein, wir brauchen euch alle. Dann weiß man, dass das Demagogie ist und das muss man auch genau so benennen. Es geht in der Politik immer um Interessen. Und wenn man die Interessen der anderen besser findet und die eher vertritt und sagt, nein, wir wollen aber den Reichen noch mehr geben, dann kann ich damit klarkommen. Dann weiß ich, das ist die Position, meine ist eine andere. Aber wenn mir jemand gegenüber sitzt und sagt, ich will jetzt mal, dass der Kanzler zu mir sagt, wir brauchen euch alle, dann ist das die größte Lüge der Welt, die man einfordert vom Kanzler, die er machen soll. Es ist Unsinn. Und deswegen haben wir einen Parlamentarismus, weil es dieses euch alle verkörpert von einer Person nicht gibt. Dann muss man sich einen König auserkürren. Dann muss man schauen, ob man Angebote bei den Reichsbürgern oder sonst wo findet. Aber das findet man nicht in einer parlamentarischen Demokratie.
Ja, die ist nicht dafür da. Der Kompromiss erfordert sowohl Servien abfeuern, eine Konfliktlage.
Ja.
Diese Mioska-Sache ist Salon-Lektüre oder?
Das ist Salon-Lektüre. Also das ist wirklich ein Highlight, verspreche ich. Wir sprechen über Mioska. Wir sprechen aber vor allem über zwei Bücher, die unterschiedlicher nicht sein könnten. Und zwar sprechen wir über das knappe Gut Arbeit von Florian Butollo. Er ist Arbeitssoziologe hier in Frankfurt, im Übrigen, und er sagt, ja, es gibt eine Automatisierung, es gibt KI, aber es gibt einen strukturellen Arbeitskräftemangel und der wird sich noch verschärfen. Die KI wird diese Probleme nicht lösen. Möglicherweise gibt es eine Ausdiffenzierung und Komplexitätssteigerung, die eher dazu führt, dass wir noch sehr viel mehr Leute brauchen. Und wo werden wir sie dann hernehmen? Denn sie sind de facto nicht vorhanden. Es ist ein sehr intelligentes Buch, das sich damit auseinandersetzt.
Fünze, also da du es jetzt als intelligent, ich möchte anmerken, ich trage das Ergebnis mit, aber der Rechenweg gefällt mir gar nicht.
Ja, das habe ich mir fast gedacht, dass das etwas ist, was bei dir Widerspruch erregt. Wo wir uns wahrscheinlich einig sind, und trotzdem ist es sinnvoll, darüber zu diskutieren, ist das Buch, das die Leute aus dem Nios Verlag herausgegeben haben. Es heißt links, deutsch, deutsch, links und soll ein Wörterbuch sein, um die Linken und ihre Sprache zu verstehen und zu entlarven.
Also es ist ein Wörterbuch nach Optik, das können wir eher sagen.
Richtig, also wir haben LEMMATA.
Danach geht es drunter und drüber.
Begriffe wie zum Beispiel Femizid, Flächenbrand, Fachkraft, Erinnerungskultur, Experte, Desinformation, Demokratische Mitte. Wir können hier an diesen Beiträgen, bei denen wirklich nicht ein einziger gut ist.
Doch, einer.
Ja, okay, ich bin sehr gespannt, welcher das dann sein wird. Aber sie gehen alle am Ziel vorbei. Also es ist, oder sagen wir dann fast alle, es ist wirklich beeindruckend, beeindruckend, wie denkfoul Menschen sein können und das dann noch in ein Buch reinschreiben. Aber was wir hier sehen, es ist, würde ich sagen, so eine Art Gründungsdokument, sollte es eine schwarz-blaue Koalition geben, dann wird das ja keine Höcke-Koalition sein. Davon darf man ausgehen. Es wird auch keine sein, die sich gegen den Transatlantizismus stellt. Es wird keine sein, die russlandfreundlich ist, weil das jetzt immer wieder gesagt wurde. Nein, es wird eine solche Koalition sein, wie sie hier in den verschiedenen Beiträgen nachzusehen ist. Also in gewisser Weise ist das schon so ein Wahlprogramm für eine schwarz-blaue Koalition. Vielleicht dann auch noch mit der FDP dabei. Wolfgang Kubicki jedenfalls kommt hier an diesem Büchlein ja auch vor. Es ist insofern aufschlussreich, aber ganz deutlich hier gesagt, nicht zum Kaufen empfohlen. Wir sprechen so drüber.
Wir sprechen so drüber. Und jetzt habe ich gesagt, ein Text davon ist gut, aber halt aus Versehen, was nur wieder zeigt, wie dumm das Buch angelegt ist. Also man hat wirklich gar nicht drüber nachgedacht.
Ja, ich weiß, was du meinst. Ja, genau, das ist interessant. Ich bringe noch Musik mit, nämlich neue Musik, eingespielt von Anne-Sophie Mutter, grandios. Dann eine Novelle, die sich mit KI-Fragen auseinandersetzt und Autor schafft. Kann man anhand eines Textes wirklich Rückschlüsse darauf ziehen, um welche Person es sich handelt? Also wir haben Profiler, die so etwas machen. Aber was ist, wenn man da als Lektor irgendwann, wo KI schon sehr weit fortgeschritten ist, einen Text erhält und dieser Text, so klingt es fast, stammt von einer einstigen Liebe. Dem geht Philipp Schöntaler nach. Um Liebe geht es auch in dem Roman von Thomas Hetzje. Der ist so kühn und hat seinen Roman einfach Liebe genannt. Da steht nur als Titel Liebe. Das muss man erstmal bringen. Wird ein Roman dem gerecht? Ja, dieser wird dem.
Gerecht, darüber werden wir sprechen, dachte so was darf nur der Vatikan. Wir lesen heute Vatikansachen und zwar gab es zum einen diesen großen Text zum Verhältnis künstlicher und menschlicher Intelligenz. Als ich ihn durchgelesen hatte, war ich zum einen fasziniert, wie man den Vatikan formuliert. Man bezieht sich ja ausschließlich auf eigene religiöse Autoren, weshalb mir gar nicht so viel, sondern erst in der letzten Zeile nach 20.000 Worten, dass das natürlich noch Franziskos 2025 war.
Ach so.
Was dem Text aber, da ich ja das, was ich eben gesagt habe, gilt, den könnte man jetzt auch in drei Jahren noch spielen. Deswegen spielen wir ihn heute, aber erst nachdem wir uns über Leos Ausführungen beim Welttag der sozialen Kommunikationsmitteln auch zum Thema KI. Also wir haben durchaus Publikationen, weiter perpest du jetzt zum Thema KI. Dann schon angesprochen im Podcast, die Maskulinisierung auf Populations reverses sex difference in fertility. Erstmals die Zäsur aus 2024 bekommen die Frauen mehr Kinder als die Männer. Jetzt kann man alle ein bisschen darüber nachdenken, wie ist das gemein und so, aber die Aufklärung wird einfach. Und wir eröffnen das Lesen einer enzyklopädischen Arbeit, die hier im Büro entstand. Mary Jane hat sich um das Infermezzo als Grundbegriff gekümmert.
Infermezzo?
Infermezzo, das ist also aus zwei Worten zusammengebaut. Aufklärung dazu gleich im Salon. Denn das ist ein Problem, das ich auch kenne. Das ist ein Problem, das Butollo nicht kennt, weil Butollo über die KI schreibt, aber anscheinend nicht so viel mit ihr arbeitet. Und beim Thema mit der KI arbeiten, ist das Infermezzo. Also jeder wird sofort verstehen, um was es da geht, wenn man diesen Text eingeht.
Das alles kann man hören, wenn man unseren Salon abonniert. Möglich ist das über Steady, Apple und Patreon. Am besten geht man auf die Seite neu20er.de. Dort findet man dann die Links. Das ist auch die Möglichkeit, um unseren Podcast zu unterstützen. Wir bedanken uns bei allen, die das schon tun und freuen uns über neue Mitglieder. Wir diskutieren also jetzt sehr ausführlich über Butollo und linksdeutsch, deutsch links. Danach dann unsere Empfehlungen. Und wir wollen noch darauf hinweisen, am 22. August sind wir in Frankfurt zu erleben. Dann gibt es den Sommer-Live-Podcast mit uns beiden. Jetzt erstmal viel Vergnügen beim Salon.
Bis gleich.